elle s'est révélée au grand public
pendant la campagne présidentielle comme
porte-parole de Marine Le Pen mais son
engagement remonte aux années 90 mon
invité a de l'énergie à revendre et une
fois inébranlable
[Musique]
bonjour Laure La Valette bonjour Clément
alors vous êtes catholique vous en
parlez assez ouvertement cette fois elle
tient une place importante dans votre
vie lors de la dernière rentrée
parlementaire c'est donc logiquement
vous avez assisté comme d'autres députés
à cette messe qui est consacrée au
parlementaire en la basilique
Sainte-Clotilde tout près de l'assemblée
et à cette occasion vous avez dressé un
parallèle entre l'engagement politique
et la charité vous avez expliqué que la
quête du bien commun c'est aussi une
sorte de charité suprême donc la
recherche du bien commun c'est
effectivement la charité que l'on doit à
son peuple est-ce que vous vous seriez
engagé en politique si vous n'avez pas
eu cette fois cette fois catholique
a sûrement après c'est difficile de
savoir parce que je suis catholique
depuis longtemps dans une famille
catholique voilà mais je pense que oui
oui parce que quand j'étais délégué de
classe en quatrième vous imaginez bien
que c'était pas du tout ma foi lié à ma
foi vous faites quand même un lien vous
parlez de dire bien sûr oui si j'ai
réfléchi je pense qu'il y a une forme de
charité je vais aller même vous dire il
y a une forme de sacerdoce aussi quand
on voit le temps que ça prend les je
vais dire c'est un engagement quand même
plein et entier qui engage aussi quand
même finalement sa famille ce qui n'est
pas toujours très simple donc oui je
pense qu'il y a une forme de charité la
recherche du bien commun puisque on est
je pense quand on s'engage en politique
tous amoureux du bien commun mais même
mes adversaires politiques sont
j'imagine bien amoureux du bien commun
même si nous ne partageons pas forcément
la même définition de ce bien commun il
n'empêche que voilà après vous savez la
foi dans ma vie voilà j'étais à la messe
de rentrer pour tout vous dire je n'y
suis pas retourné depuis c'est beaucoup
trop tôt le mercredi matin alors toutes
les religions portent un regard sur la
société ce qui les amène parfois à
intervenir dans dans le débat public et
le 9 octobre 2022 c'était à l'occasion
de la messe de canonisation d'un évêque
italien le pape François a pris la
parole on va réécouter un extrait la
solution
des migrants
et criminal et criminels les femmes en
ligne
devant nous
et cela fait aujourd'hui de la
Méditerranée le plus grand cimetière du
monde
l'exclusion des migrants est-ce qu'il
faut et dégoûtant
alors en tant qu' élu du rassemblement
national vous défendez une politique
migratoire restrictive et en tant que
catholique et bien vous avez le pape
François qui vous appelle qui vous ont
joint d'accueillir et de venir en aide
aux migrants comment est-ce que vous
conciliez les deux votre foi et vos
convictions politiques alors en fait je
pense qu'il y a deux tableaux quand le
pape François nous exhorte à une charité
personnelle je pense qu'il est tout à
fait dans son rôle après à la hausse il
s'adresse d'une nation d'un pays je
pense que pour le coup il faut rendre à
César ce qui lui appartient ça n'est pas
vraiment de son fait je pense qu'il
s'immissent un peu dans la souveraineté
des pays je pense que c'est le peuple
français qui doit décider de sa
politique migratoire c'est la raison
pour laquelle d'ailleurs nous voulions
un référendum et je dirais au pape
François que Saint-Augustin on parlait
déjà il disait comme on ne peut pas
s'occuper de tout le monde il faut
s'occuper de celui qui est le plus
proche comme lié par un sort avec vous
que ça soit le plus proche par les
circonstances par le lieu ou par le
temps et je pense qu' effectivement
quand on voit la situation de la France
les gens dont on doit s'occuper en
premier ce sont les Français
figurez-vous et je le déplore parce
qu'effectivement j'ai eu à me
positionner sur l'océan Viking vous
savez qu'il y a qui a abordé exactement
la question se pose et évidemment moi je
pense qu'il faut se courir ces migrants
qui sont en mer il faut surtout faire en
sorte qu'ils ne prennent plus des
risques inconsidérés en prenant la mer
et qu'il faut justement mettre fin à ses
ONG qui sont complices des passeurs mais
je reprendrai aussi les mots du cardinal
Sarah qui dit qu'en fait c'est là-bas
qu'il faut aller les aider parce que
chacun a vocation à s'épanouir en fait
sur la terre n'a pas à faire de
politique non je pense pas je pense
qu'il a pas à faire de politique par
contre je pense que c'est son rôle de
nous exhorter encore une fois à une
charité bien évidemment individuelle et
celle-là je ne la remet évidemment pas
du tout en cause d'ailleurs je vais vous
dire je me suis ému du sort des des
enfants mineurs qui sont arrivés de
l'océan Viking que la protection de
l'enfance a mis dans un hôtel au bout de
48 heures tous les enfants avaient
disparu typiquement une fois qu'ils
étaient notre sol moi je m'en suis émue
j'en ai parlé au président du conseil
départemental je pense qu'on a mis ses
enfants en danger il y a un autre sujet
en revanche sous l'église est intervenu
dans le champ politique et où cette fois
vous l'avez suivi c'est l'opposition au
mariage pour tous quelle est la
différence entre la question des
migrants et la question du mariage pour
tous c'est ce qui a un domaine où vous
jugez que l'intervention de l'église est
plus légitime que d'autres non mais elle
est très différente il y a encore une
fois je pense que l'Église enfin j'ai
pas souvenir pour avoir été déjà dans
les manifs c'était quand même pas une
procession il y avait énormément
de Toulon par exemple là clairement
appelé à la mobilisation contre la loi
tobira que les évêques que les papes
parlent c'est très bien après je pense
que c'est aux politiques d'en faire d'en
faire ce qu'ils veulent là il y a c'est
très différent par rapport à la fin à la
comment dire à la politique migratoire
voilà moi je pensais que c'était un
changement un changement de civilisation
qui n'allait pas dans la mesure où je
pense que le mariage n'est pas là pour
célébrer l'amour mais il est là pour
célébrer la fondation du d'une famille
avec une descendance encore une fois une
natalité aussi qui permet au pays de
bien vivre parce que c'est important
pour chaque enfant de savoir qu'il a un
père et une mère et que c'est de lui
mentir que de dire qu'il a deux papas ou
deux mamans il y a forcément une gamète
du sexe différent à un moment donné on
va parler de votre engagement au Front
National et qui remonte à loin vous êtes
engagé autour de l'âge de 15 ans je
crois oui j'ai une carte de façon un peu
anecdotique à 16 ans qu'est-ce qui a
déclenché cet engagement aussi tôt mon
papa avait fait déjà deux élections
législatives Jean-Philippe La Valette
voilà c'est présenté deux fois aux
élections législatives il a exactement
il a été présent en 1972 oui c'est ça et
avant cela il faisait partie du
mouvement d'extrême droite ordre nouveau
c'était un autre un autre contexte quand
on dit ça maintenant vous dites extrême
droite c'était un moment j'allais dire
en mai 68 ou tout était quand même très
très exacerbé mais effectivement il a
toujours eu des toujours eu à coeur de
préserver la souveraineté de son pays
alors vous avez aussi eu un engagement
syndical à la fac de droit de Bordeaux
vous y avez présidé la section du
renouveau étudiant qui est à l'époque
qui était un syndicat proche du Front
national
récemment l'hebdomadaire L'Express a
révélé que ces années d'engagement
syndicale étudiant ont été marqués par
des actions violentes sur le campus de
Bordeaux la presse régionale de l'époque
s'en est fait l'écho à plusieurs
reprises relatant des incidents violents
impliquant votre syndicat évoquant des
expéditions punitives en quelque sorte
menées par des personnes liées à votre
syndicat parfois des membres de votre
syndicat avec des marteaux des battes de
baseball des gaz lacrymogènes est-ce que
c'est un passé que vous assumez il faut
remettre un peu les choses dans leur
contexte c'était dans les années 97 je
pense 96 ou les facs qui avaient
effectivement de la violence sur les
facs mais à tel point même que les
renseignements territoriaux faisaient un
peu un focus sur ce moment-là parce
qu'il disait que c'était très révélateur
des tensions que l'on que l'on trouvait
dans dans la société il y avait le local
de lunettes à côté d'une autre et
c'était un pas un peu tendu je pense ce
ce comment dire cet article du stagiaire
de L'Express essaye de me faire passer
pour un skinhead plutôt marrant je
trouve que personne n'est dupe en 1998
cet engagement politique c'est
concrétisé par votre première
candidature anélection c'était au
cantonal là vous allez sortir le dossier
de la voilà c'est ça voilà on affiche
vous aviez 22 ans à l'époque vous étiez
étudiante ça vous a valu des remarques
non ça m'a valu de planter mon année par
contre parce que coller des affiches et
faire les marchés globalement vous êtes
moins vous êtes moins sur votre télé non
non ça m'a pas valu du tout de remarque
je crois que j'étais la une la femme je
pense que j'étais la plus jeune de
France alors je sais plus si c'est au
sein du Front national ou carrément de
tous les candidats et non c'était une
sacrée expérience c'était à Bègles fief
de Noël ma mère où j'ai quand même fait
10,33% ce qui était quand même assez fou
belle une belle expérience militante et
alors dans ce parcours politique juste
après ou peu après il y a eu une sorte
d'écart une forme d'infidélité au Front
national à l'époque c'était le FN vous
avez quitté le une poursuite Bruno
Maigret au MNR pourquoi en fait je pense
qu'on avait envie de dédiabolisation un
peu on avait envie on était un peu
lassés des provocations que pouvait
avoir Jean-Marie Le Pen quand vous
passiez vos nuits à coller que le
lendemain matin il faisait une grosse
bourde à la radio vous disiez minimum ça
a pas de sens on est de l'Union des
droits
de des diabolisation vraiment de se dire
qu'on qu'on allait gagner quoi qu'on
voulait le pouvoir bon avec un peu de
recul je me dis qu'effectivement et pas
un charisme de malade mais
finalement ce qui est assez marrant
c'est de se dire que finalement ce que
j'avais cherché au MNR c'est Marine Le
Pen qui me l'a offert avec sa vision du
rassemblement national vous avez ensuite
fait une pause dans votre engagement
politique fonder votre famille vous
l'avez évoqué vous avez eu cinq enfants
dont une fille qui est trisomique c'est
ça vous êtes très engagé sur les
questions de handicap vous pensez vous
aujourd'hui en tant que député vous avez
l'espoir de pouvoir améliorer les
politiques publiques sur ce j'aimerais
en fait je pense que ce qu'il y a pas
mal marqué aussi mon engagement quand
Marine me demande d'être porte-parole en
charge enfin thématique en charge du
handicap évidemment j'accepte tout de
suite et je pense que ce qu'il y a bien
marché c'est que moi je partage le
quotidien des Français quand vous avez
cinq enfants quand vous avez une petite
fille handicapée vous savez qu'à 6 mois
d'attente dans les dossiers à la Maison
Départementale de des personnes
handicapées vous savez que parcoursup
c'est un peu de la daube et de parler
aux gens finalement de vraiment ce qui
les concerne et de le vivre vous-même je
pense que ça vous enracite et je pense
que c'est un peu ce qu'a fait pas le
succès mais le fait que les Français
même bien en tout cas les Français que
je rencontre sur les marchés aiment
cette cette proximité que j'ai avec eux
et c'est vrai que si je pouvais
améliorer les choses pour le handicap ce
serait évidemment et alors une bonne
chose pour revenir à cette question du
handicap vous voulez vous avez dit que
l'engagement était une forme de
sacerdoce que ça prenait beaucoup de
temps sur la famille comment est-ce
qu'on gère cela quand on a un enfant qui
a forcément besoin de un peu plus de
temps et d'attention exactement alors
c'est pas très simple et c'est une une
vraie question alors la chance que j'ai
c'est qu'elle est relativement autonome
donc c'est quand même plus simple
euh et puis on se rend compte aussi
qu'on est aidant et finalement bah les
frères et soeurs mettent plus la main à
la pâte parce que c'est moi qui l'amené
le matin c'est moi qui ont pris le le
relais assez naturellement et puis je
n'hésite pas à me faire aider quand j'en
ai besoin mais c'est une vraie question
ça veut quand même dire que finalement
beaucoup de gens sont aidants sans s'en
apercevoir je ne me suis jamais dit que
j'étais aidante jamais dit que mes
enfants étaient aidants et en fait
d'avoir été un peu extrait de ma famille
typiquement ça fait trois jours que je
suis à Paris il faut que le reste tourne
mais on s'aperçoit que la famille est un
maillon fondamental je crois que c'est à
peu près 11 millions de dents mais qui
sont déclarés donc ça veut dire que
comme moi certains ne savent pas qu'ils
le sont allez c'est l'heure de notre
quiz à présent alors je vous explique le
principe vous commencez une phrase
exactement vous connaissez déjà et c'est
ça donc je commence une phrase à vous de
la compléter donc vous êtes porte-parole
du groupe RN à l'Assemblée le secret
pour être une bonne porte-parole c'est
rester naturel rester un peu insolente
beaucoup travaillé et surtout continuer
à aimer les Français
en arrivant à l'Assemblée je m'attendais
je ne m'attendais pas à ce que c'est
soit aussi exaltant et aussi passionnant
que du positif il y a pas eu de mauvaise
surprise ou de couvrais c'est une chance
folle d'être dans cette maison qui est
magnifique et puis qu'elle ça au nord je
veux dire ça oblige d'être là et de
représenter les Français c'est une
grande joie j'aurais réussi mon mandat
si si vous savez quoi j'ai déjà
l'impression de d'y être un peu arrivé
j'ai porté la cause de Emma jeune fille
poli handicapée sur ma circonscription
qui avait été mise à la porte de son
établissement comme 17 autres familles
et d'avoir pu parler d'Emma directement
au ministre Combes en commission à faire
sociale et je me suis dit bah même si ça
s'arrête je regrette pas d'être venu
pour Emma merci beaucoup Laure La
Valette d'être venu dans la politique et
moi Merci à VOUS Clément mec
[Musique]